there we were listening to the turkish
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan giving
his address to the UN General Assembly
he talks of justice or rather injustice
around the world that was a common
thread through his speech let's get more
on it from Al Jazeera's Hashim ah Jabara
who is live for us at the UN Hashem we
did see a red chip type Arab and almost
taking a leaf out of the Israeli
president say it was really prime
ministers book with all his Show and
Tell slides but they were focusing very
much on this common threads of injustice
that ran through at the Turkish
president speech indeed and this is
something that has been reiterated over
the last few years here's here at the
United Nations particularly on the need
to reform the United Nation and the
international community to reinvent
itself to be able to tackle issues like
injustice and inequality staying at a
certain point that the international
community is no longer able to deal with
those issues
he spoke about a wide range of issues
Islamophobia Kashmir the plight of rural
India the death of the former Egyptian
President Mohammed mostly the murder of
the started journalist democracy in the
sand the consulate in Istanbul but two
issues dominated his statement today
Syria where he said that basically his
country cannot handle his own the
growing number of Syrian refugees under
the international community and the
Europeans should honor the commitments
made in 2013 whereby Turkey stems the
flow of migrants in exchange for the
European Union to provide billions of
euros of H of the Turkish government he
said that also his government is
negotiating with the Americans that need
to implement the safe zone eastern of
the Euphrates and he said specifically
that the Turkish government is asking
for a 30 kilometer deep security safe
security zone along the border with
Syria to be able to combat groups
affiliated with the PKK and the YPG
which is an offshoot military arm of the
SDF considered by the Turkish government
as a terrorist organization where the
Americans consider them to be strong
allies in the fight against
I said and also he said that the new
constitutional committee which has been
here announced yesterday by the United
Nations secretary-general about Syria
could be a good step forward to worse
permanent peace now he spoke also about
the israeli-palestinian issue saying
that the Israeli government over the
last few decades has been expanding the
settlements and the Palestinian
territory at the same time has been
shrinking lashing out at the Israeli
government and the international
community saying that the UN has failed
to implement the resolutions it produced
over the last few decades to bring about
two-state solutions an Israeli and a
Palestinian independent state okay
Hashem Jabara thank you very much indeed
sir but listening to that speech with me
as sort of Barak at the director of the
Center for conflict and humanitarian
studies at Doha Institute's he joins us
on set we both had a collective gasp
when the first slide winds up and the
the body of young Island currency on the
beach was shown and it did serve to
underline the point that he was making
at the particularly in regard to Syria
that there is injustice and very few
countries are shouldering that blame
well I think the bigger point was he
wanted to remind the rest of the world
of what Turkey is carrying in terms of
responsibility and cause when it comes
to Syria and as such the solution that
he has in mind of the security zone is
something that has to be taken seriously
of course the United States I think will
disagree with that and this is not a new
proposal he's put this proposal some
time ago and there's been a huge
opposition to it partly because he kind
of mix up integrity territorial
integrity of Syria with the demand that
is very much turkey demand of the
eradication of the YPG or the Kurdish
Syrian movement which is now supported
by by the United States and also of
course this discussion that if we secure
a zone a stretch of 30 kilometer we can
have two or three million people
returning that's very unrealistic
because this to three million should
really in the name of justice that order
and calls for should return to where
they've come from
that you cannot just return them into
these border areas to be exposed for for
potential future conflict but one
important point I think he made about
Syria is the threat of of ad lib and as
you know throughout the conflict as it
as they were resolving issues in one
area moving to the next they've allowed
the fighters to withdraw into ad lib and
now ad live has become a very dangerous
mix of fighters who have a real cause to
fight for and a mix of terrorists and
some extreme groups and that could
provide the pretext for the Syrian
government and potentially others to act
against them and that could lead to a
huge wave of displacement into Turkey
again and having said that of course no
one denies the generosity of Turkey when
it comes to dealing with Syrians they
did actually you know in in real terms
they they Illustrated a lesson to
everyone around the world of how a
nation should really stand by its
neighbors and they've burdened a huge
cost when it comes to the Syrians the
Syrian issue is one where the UN has
been quite bogged down has it not we saw
that the announcement of that committee
to help start rebuilding the
constitution but there's it was an
announcement the very few were healing
doesn't be they have been backed down
but that is a major breakthrough it
happened a couple of days ago and go
terror spoke about it earlier today the
committee it's an agreed committee it's
a Syrian or all Syrian committee and is
going to put the Constitution so if
turkey come in support of that as well I
think it will achieve what everyone
desires and that is the end of conflict
in Syria okay well thank you very much
for your analysis there great to get
your thoughts and let's move on notes